[Music]
apartment rents in las vegas
rising rapidly there's a new report by
the nevada state apartment association
showing local rents growing by 18
percent
through the end of the second quarter of
2021 that is compared to last year
the average rent sits at thirteen
hundred dollars now these high prices
high rents concerning many renters which
have seen their
bills go up the past couple of years
kate houston spoke to a local mom about
her rent increase
and digs into why they're going up when
we first moved here it was pretty cheap
nicole jane is a single mom renting a
two-bedroom apartment
her rent has gone up nearly 200 dollars
over the past
three years that did put quite a you
know bit of strain on me these last few
months especially
jane is not alone the nevada state
apartment association
says rent increases have doubled since
the beginning of the year
for workers like jane who have had to
take furlough days and pay cuts during
the pandemic
this is a frustrating situation that was
you know an added
stressor for for me personally because
you know you got a child
i'm making less money than you know i
used to
and plus my rent and other bills went up
so
why are prices going up local property
manager steve hawk says one reason
is extremely high demand and low supply
apartment availability is going down
with the vacancy at only 4.3 percent
that's why we're seeing prices go above
and beyond what locals can
afford most locals cannot afford las
vegas anymore hawks says apartments are
capitalizing on those moving from out of
state who are still saving money with
the local rent increases
they don't care about three or four
hundred bucks they just made a half a
million or a million dollars on their
house in california
they don't care they just want a place
to live and be comfortable the nvsaa
says there are nearly 4 thousand
apartment units under construction in
las vegas
even with more supply on the way jane
says the prices are not realistic
for families try to find someplace else
you know
another area because it's just it's
becoming unaffordable here
kate houston 8 news now now to give you
an idea of the amount of people moving
here clark county's population has
grown by two percent in the past year
that's about 40
000 people that have been moved here in
the past year alone
the nvsaa says that makes it one of the
top 10
fastest growing metro areas in the
country